hey guys Mary here at PAX Prime 2015 and
we're working with the mix to bring you
guys some sweet indie games and I'm here
with Tim Conkling how are you doing I'm
great thank you awesome and you were
gonna show us antihero today yes let's
jump right into it okay so antihero
is a single-player and multiplayer
strategy game about running a Thieves
Guild okay so the idea behind this game
is it's a civilization style 4x strategy
but rather than covering you know the
expansive human history and all of the
continent you're all of the world you
are you're basically like infiltrating
and burgling and blackmailing and
bribing within the confines of this
Charles Dickens inspiring city yeah you
all those things you said are really bad
and you look like a thief so are a lot
of the things that you're doing here
you're actually you're stealing you're
like kind of hurting people to to
succeed in to progress in the game
exactly but the the city that you are
stated in the in is overrun by
corruption and greed so well they're all
bad to them right all right so you're
sort of the lesser of two you all right
let's see what we got going on here okay
so to start with I'm gonna get my
economy up and running okay so I'm gonna
build a kitchen in in my guilty and that
gives me an emergen is that your kitchen
so that's that kitchens produce virgins
so the the way the game works is the the
city is divided into these colored
districts and each district Yukon
each district each district has a
building in it that can be infiltrated
and when a building is infiltrated you
get resources over - okay
all right so you right now your your
building resources right right so so
basically I'm playing right now against
a very docile
okay but the game is designed to be
played there's a single-player campaign
where you go through a story that tells
you the tale of runaway urgent girl who
makes her way into the city and under
the auspices of the master thief but the
game is also designed to be really fast
play paced asynchronous multiplayer okay
so the idea is it's it's like
civilization material Academy you have
turns that take about a minute or two
and a total game takes about 30 turns or
so so the idea is that you have multiple
games running simultaneously and you're
you're managing a bunch of guilds
against friends and enemies all over the
world okay so this is all done through
random online or you want to be playing
against your friends both yeah start off
playing against your friends and then go
compete against stranger thieves all
right so what are you doing right now so
so I'm exploring the city and upgrading
my guild and my master thief so that the
way the game works is there are their
two currencies there's gold that you get
from burglary and the occasional
assassination okay so you're just
robbing people right for currency and
there are lanterns that you get from
infiltrating certain buildings okay so
gold is used to recruit units so I'm
gonna recruit some more urgent
so these urchins are kind of your worker
units they they work plots of land or in
this case buildings to get you more
resources to get you more resources and
power-ups and upgrades all right I know
what are you planning on doing with
these resources so I'm gonna Scout over
here to lessor plug and this is my
opponents Thieves Guild right here okay
he's that's enemy urgent yep so again
I'm playing against a really docile AI
so for we're showing it the indie mini
booth and we have sort of a tutorial
tutorial setup so this is this is level
one but I'm going to start wrecking
house here yeah let's let's take them
down real fast
so you're beginning your attacks here
right so I've just committed yeah so
I've just basically like cut off one of
his supply lines the the goal of the
game is to get victory points before
your opponent does and you get victory
points by infiltrating churches to get
blackmail
there are assassination contracts that
both you and your opponent get and the
first person to assassin that
assassinate the contract gets it and
there are bribes that you buy in your
guild so basically like there's an
economic and military and an exploration
in the victory so it's not just um a
point base there's exactly there are
always yeah there are violent and
nonviolent ways to attack the game
what's the final what's that oh you just
have all sorts of items there there's so
much more to uncover here we haven't
even touched pancreas court or West
worms berries yeah you really don't want
to go to pancreas we're not going to
text it more difficult well I wish we
could continue looking at it it looks
like this is the kind of game where it
takes a lot more time to kind of uncover
all the different elements that you have
going on here exactly yeah it's a slow
paced or a fast paced but turn-based
strategy game and when can people expect
to get antihero we're gonna be releasing
sometime in early 2016
okay on PC yeah we'll be on Steam Mac
and PC first and then sometime later on
iOS and Android
awesome Tim thank you so much for
showing me organize me alright well that
was anti-hero for the latest in all
indie games be sure to stay tuned to
games.com